[Music]
welcome back
so i'm really excited today to derive
for you the potential flow vector field
which is essentially a solution of
laplace's equation so this is one of my
absolute favorite lectures because we're
starting to really put the pieces
together of what we learned from vector
calculus div grad and curl and we're
going to use those to derive one of the
most important partial differential
equations in all of physics this
describes gravitational and electric
potentials away from masses and charges
it describes the you know steady-state
heat equation in an object and it also
describes uh lots of approximate fluid
flows that were designed used in the
early years of aircraft design
so really exciting we're going to
develop the potential flow in laplace's
equation right now
and specifically
we are going to define the potential
flow as a steady
incompressible irrotational flow
so this is a steady and i'm going to
define these mathematically in a minute
a steady
incompressible
incompressible
meaning it can't be compressed it's a
divergence free
if you like and irrotational
irrotational
so there's no curl or no rotation of the
flow
so potential flow is a steady
incompressible irrotational flow
v
the
[Music]
arrow and we're going to assume that
this is a two-dimensional
a two-dimensional vector field v1 v2
which are functions of x and y
and so mathematically what we mean by
steady
steady here
means
that dv dt equals zero so partial v
partial t
equals zero so there this is not
changing in time it's fixed for all of
time uh incompressible
income
pressable
again we already know what
incompressible means it means that the
divergence of v is equal to zero
the divergence
of v
is equal to zero so it's not kind of
sourcing or sinking
and irrotational
irrotational
means that the curl of my vector field
the curl of my vector field
uh is equal to zero okay good so um
this is what we mean by a steady
incompressible irrotational flow
now at the very outset this seems
extremely restrictive it seems like this
is going to be too restrictive and maybe
these flows won't be interesting at all
because we're putting so many
constraints on them
but again it turns out that with these
constraints
we still have a really really powerful
class of flow fields or
vector fields given uh given by these
constraints
and so let me also write down what these
are in components just uh just because
we're going to use these later so
incompressibility means that partial
v1 partial x
plus partial v2 partial y
is equal to zero
and the curl condition means that
partial
v2 with respect to x partial v2 with
respect to x
minus partial v1 with respect to y
equals zero
so we're looking for vector fields that
satisfy
the satisfy these properties okay now
what vector fields actually satisfy
these so it turns out
that let me just draw a line here so
this is what we want and i'm going to
show you what vector fields actually
satisfy this so
incompressibility and irrotationality
are automatically satisfied so these
are satisfied automatically these are
satisfied
automatically
if we have a gradient flow
if
v
equals the gradient of some potential
fee
for a real valued potential for
a real
valued
potential
fee we've already talked about potential
fields and gradient flows so this is a
gradient flow this is automatically
satisfied for a real value potential fee
that satisfies
that satisfies
del squared phi equals zero
and this is laplace's equation so this
is the extremely important
laplace's equation
and you already know how much
i like and respect and admire laplace
so laplace's name is on the eiffel tower
um one of the great great mathematicians
uh
um
this is laplace's equation
okay so
i'm going to to kind of demonstrate for
you that this is absolutely true that if
we have a potential function fee that
satisfies laplace's equation then by
construction the gradient flow
associated is incompressible and
irrotational
and because this is not changing in time
it's also steady okay that one we get it
kind of for free
so we know
that gradient fields are always
irrotational so this is true so
irrotationality is true for any any
gradient flow
so it's really whether or not
incompressibility is true for this
particular gradient flow
and so
one thing we could do is we could
literally just take the divergence of
this
and show that we get laplace's equation
so that's what i'm going to do
so
am i going too fast maybe i'm going too
fast let me say this again this is
really really important
we want
a vector field v
that is steady incompressible and
irrotational
we can automatically get irrotationality
and steadiness just for any potential
flow any gradient of a scalar potential
will be irrotational and steady as long
as this doesn't change in time
but for us to have also
incompressibility
we need this potential to be a very very
special potential fee that satisfies
laplace's equation
so what i'm going to show is that if
laplace's equation is true then the
divergence of this vector field is equal
to 0.
so let's compute div v
so the divergence of v
is equal to
the dot product of partial partial x
partial partial y i apologize for my
squeaky marker i know it drives some of
you crazy
that's the the del dot
and v is equal to grad phi so this is
partial phi partial x
and partial phi partial y
remember if i take the gradient of a
scalar i get a vector of its partial
derivatives
and so now the dot product the
divergence of this gradient field
is equal to
um just the product of the first two
elements plus the product of the second
two elements
so this is the second partial derivative
partial squared phi partial x squared
plus
partial squared two partial derivatives
of y plus partial squared phi
partial y squared
and this is the definition of the
laplacian operator so div
of grad of fee is the laplacian operator
so kind of by construction this is
the definition of noble squared
fee
and we've already said that this is
equal to zero that was our our
constraint is that uh we're only dealing
with potential functions fee that are
the solution of laplace's equation
and so this is equal to zero because
this is equal to 0.
and so what we've shown here is that if
our vector field v
is the gradient of a potential that
satisfies laplace's equation we get
incompressibility
for free
and we already had irrotationality
because it's a gradient field
okay so this is extremely extremely
useful
uh this laplace's equation comes up
everywhere comes up all throughout the
physical sciences
and this is a particularly important set
of vector fields this potential flow
vector field we're going to use it to
analyze fluid flows that are
irrotational and incompressible okay
good so
what else do i want to tell you
the solutions of laplace's equation are
an incredibly important class of
functions
that have really deep roots in complex
variable theory
so maybe i'll briefly show you what that
looks like
in in complex variable theory
so if i have a
analytic complex function
so
i'm going to assume that you know
something about complex variables
so if we have
z a z variable equals x
plus i y okay so this is a real plus
imaginary part and this is a complex
variable
then i can have functions like
z squared that is a complex function of
the complex variable
z
and this is called an analytic function
because it can be
kind of reduced to a simple expression
in terms of this elemental variable z
the the real part of z or the amplitude
of z is not an analytic function because
it can't be written as like a power
series or taylor series expansion of z
anyway a lot of background uh
complex variables z analytic functions
of z like polynomials things like that
uh cosine sines e to the z
and so if i have a complex
potential i can take
if i have a complex potential
phi of z
which is equal to
[Music]
this little guy here little phi
of x and y
plus i times psi
of x and y
then
this is called a complex potential
this is my potential function and this
is my stream function and what i'm going
to show you is that for analytic
functions phi of z like z squared z
cubed e to the z sine of z cosine of z
for special complex functions v of z
the potential function and the stream
function both satisfy laplace's equation
and so you can take the gradient of this
and get a potential flow
now i'm going to go a lot more into
detail in this uh in in more lectures so
if this is going kind of fast that's
okay we're going to dig in deeper here
but i want to tell you why kind of and
how we're going to find these vector
fields that are the gradient
of potentials which are the solution of
laplace's equation
so this is a whole huge field of complex
analysis to find these functions so
again i'm going to call this the
potential function
potential function
and this is called the stream function
and these have real meanings for fluid
flows and this is some complex
complex potential
and again
if phi i'm just going to write this out
if
big phi
of z
is an analytic
function and this this has a real
meaning in the complex plane it means we
satisfy the koshi riemann conditions
and it also means that if you take the
derivative of this function
no matter how you approach that
derivative
with like little delta x's or delta y's
or delta z is approaching zero you get
the same answer it's a very intuitive
definition of a
function for analytic
functions phi of z
and again i mean like
z squared z cubed dot dot all
polynomials
cosine of z and sine of z
e to the z
turns out log of z away from the origin
is analytic
so any nicely behaved analytic function
phi of z
then
then both
the real and the imaginary parts phi
and psi
satisfy laplace's equation
satisfy
laplace's equation laplace's
equation
um so what we have is
del squared phi equals zero
and del squared psi
equals zero
and you could actually derive this so
this is actually a condition for for a
function to be analytic
its real and imaginary parts have to
satisfy laplace's equation so that's
actually a functional working definition
of what an analytic function of the
complex plane is and you can essentially
uh write this out explicitly for the
real and the imaginary parts of phi and
z and you can kind of set them equal and
show that there are conditions on on you
know what this has to be for these to be
analytic functions
okay good um
so what we have done is we've derived
the conditions to have a potential flow
that is steady incompressible and
irrotational
we've related it
very concretely to
laplace's equation so the potentials are
solutions of laplace's equations
and those are intimately related to this
field of complex analysis uh called
analytic function theory okay
now what we're going to do in future
lectures is we're going to start taking
specific examples of phi of z
like z squared this z squared
actually establishes
a real and an imaginary part
that are solutions of laplace's equation
and give us potential flow fields so we
can take z squared if you want to do
this as a homework before the next
lecture
go through the the math of expanding out
z squared can
collect its real and imaginary parts
take its real part which is a potential
function
and compute its gradient field and show
that the gradient field is
incompressible irrotational maybe plot
the vector field
and that'll really start convincing you
that you can actually use these analytic
functions
to develop these really interesting and
powerful class of vector fields that are
related to laplace's equation
okay excellent uh so a lot more on this
we'll talk about different types of
potential flows and all about laplace's
equation will go way way more into depth
in laplace's equation soon all right
thank you